if the person's doing the vision board
and they're saying when i get my new car
i get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great
now that well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful you feel a love
for life you feel a joy for existence
you feel a passion
uh
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated
in by the universe into wealth you will
be initiated into health you'll be
initiated into freedom those people
all those people that have healed
themselves of all those different health
conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great that
they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've they've left that program behind
a long time ago they actually don't care
how you think of them they they actually
are so happy with themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn some law of
attraction secrets and how you can use
it enjoy
number two is change the program with
bruce lipton when you're putting in a
wish and a desire put it in as if you
already have it
i am healthy
uh i am a good relationship person uh
you know i have a great job that what's
that i say it's like i already have it
and yet most people don't have it so
they'll say i want a great job i want a
great relationship i want to be healthy
and i go make a recording of those words
we just said that i want to be healthy
today right now tuesday we're going to
make a recording i say now come back in
one year and let's push the button on
that recording and we come back a year
later and it says i want to be healthy i
go it's a whole year and you still want
to be healthy still don't have it right
you're going to say i am healthy
all you're emphasizing i have a desire
to be healthy i want to be healthy i
have a desire to be held and i go
you can have that desire the rest of
your life you're not going to get
healthy you want to be healthy say i am
healthy but then you look and say yeah
but in reality i'm sick
and i go no no
the function of the mind is to take the
program and turn it into reality so if i
am sick but i put a program in i am
healthy the mind looks you know like
well wait a second the program is i am
healthy but the body is not healthy so
what's the function of the mind
create health in the body it doesn't
change the program
it changes the body and so the idea is
this every time we put a program in it
has to be as if you already have it in
spite of the fact you could be dying of
cancer i go i am healthy
it sounds kind of weird and i go don't
worry about it just put it on i am
healthy because once it is a program the
function of the mind is to manifest it
as reality
that's the part and so my little caveat
you brought it up i'm emphasizing it and
that was simply this
that whatever you're downloading you
have to say it as if you already have it
because if you put a future tense on it
i will i want i say
if you record that that means you will
always will you know want to have it you
know i will do this you won't get there
so i just wanted to bring that in
because if we're making a program then
you must make sure it says as if you
already have it in spite of the fact you
don't also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
i've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
secret number three is visualize when
you think a deliberate thought of what
you want
um then law of attraction will employ
the universe
and all people circumstances and events
to
move you to what you've asked for and to
move what you've asked for to you
and so
if if if you think about that
there is just action
would be really really hard for you to
reach all of the people circumstances
and events manipulate all of them
to receive what you want and if you
really reflect well on your life and
things that have happened in your life
you'll kind of see
that
actually that happened for me
ah all i did was move to here or all i
did was move to there and
i received what i wanted thought creates
all of the appearances in the world and
thought creates everything in your life
so it's pretty darn powerful right
and what you think about is what you get
what you focus on is what will manifest
in your life and everyone is manifesting
their day every single day we're doing
it um we are not aware of course
necessarily of thoughts but thoughts
come we energize them and then they will
manifest unless we
cancel that thought out
um with another thought with a thought
that contradicts it but i remember
lester levinson would say
every single thought manifests
and i just thought that was incredible i
had known the secret for years and years
and years and lester levinson was a real
master
um and he said every single thought
manifests and i was just wow
that's how powerful they are
so
so thoughts are your superpower
to be do and have
what you want to experience and have and
do in your life
and and so if you ask
um an athlete or if you talk to a coach
a really brilliant coach right of a
sports team then you will find that
visualization
and these principles that i'm talking
about are a big part of their training
they have to be they have to see
themselves winning the game they have to
see themselves winning the match there
is a really incredible tennis player
that's a very big fan
a champion tennis player that's a really
big fan of the secret who uses the
sacred this is what he does he sees that
he has won the match before he walks out
onto that court
and and it's the same for
um
for teams it's the same for athletes in
the olympic games running a race and
seeing that they've won yes they run the
race but what has them win the race is
that they saw themselves winning before
they even got on the starting block
and they saw it and believed it and felt
it and so they just everything lined up
for them in the perfect way they drew
the perfect lane everybody else was was
moved in exactly the right position and
they got a really great start and they
won the race
and so
thought is just so so powerful so
athletes but also do you know the
astronauts in the apollo um
program did visualization
before they went to the moon and
they visualized
landing back on earth safely
and so that's how important the
visualization visualization is just
bought in pictures by the way it's it's
it's still thought it's just the same
thing okay it's just thought in pictures
so if you took a person who had
zero resistance
and you locked them in a room
you know if you took a person that had
zero resistance that person thought
about what they wanted zero resistance
lock them in a room what they wanted
will come to them
the universe will move people
circumstances and events and bring that
right to them it might it absolutely
must
because if you have no resistance you
have unleashed a law that just cannot be
stopped
and so you will manifest it will come to
you secret number four is pay attention
to the right things with dave meltzer i
saw the secret a year ago i was not
someone who believed in the i didn't
even know i didn't understand the
ability to manifest i had never heard
conceptually about that so for me i was
just exposed to this a year ago and i
thought there's nothing i can lose here
by writing down what i'd like to
manifest and then taking it to the next
level and then trace it and then speak
it into existence and all learning about
opening your mind to learn about all
these things has a domino effect
wouldn't you agree that you start
finding yourself having contact with
other people who are masters in this or
experts in this well that's because
there's a mathematical formula to this
that i try to break things down to a
really simplistic level so what we pay
attention to
and then we give it intention
creates the coincidences in our lives
and coinciding is a mathematical term to
me it's not an accident it's two things
that are perfectly coming together at a
perfect time the right way at a perfect
time so i'm very cognizant of what i pay
attention to and the intention i give it
so that i get the coincidences that i
want in my life and it really works as a
mathematical equation i make it a
consistent persistent practice to pay
attention to the right things now here's
where it takes another level for me is i
thought about faith you know like i'm
gonna put faith in this and that got
really confusing because i aggregated
what i think say do and believe and i
even started looking at the unconscious
competencies my genetics of personality
traits characteristics obsessions and
addictions and how all these things were
my faith no religious context at all
then i met
a guy who wrote atomic
habits james clear and he talked about
voting and i started saying faith is
like voting i'm just gonna vote for what
i want and my biggest mistakes in my
life i'm always voting for what other
people want for me and then i'm pissed
off when i get it and i'm resentful when
i get it and i'm just very hard now i
know what i'm voting for and i know it's
going to be elected into my life and so
i keep voting for what i want and if my
mind tells me something that i don't
want i don't vote for it and i see so
many people voting for what they don't
want and then really upset or resentful
or offended when they get it or even
surprised and so i think all of these
things combined together combined to
voting is what i'm paying attention to
the intention is the action right so
it's not just paying attention and
saying i want this or thinking about it
it's actually get off your butt don't
sit at home high on your mom's couch
sick do something about it be efficient
effective productive and accessible we
were talking earlier i heard you dave
doesn't like busy no i hate busy busy
means unaccessible
i'm active i have activity i get paid
for activity and i don't get paid for
i'm productive and accessible i provide
value and i'm accessible to what i want
and accessible to others secret number
five is surrender with gabrielle
bernstein when we stop expecting things
to be the way that we think they should
be when we stop forcing outcomes and
when we start allowing what is of the
highest good to be our only agenda our
only intention
that's when the universe truly has our
back that's when we can
live what it means to surrender true
surrender comes when we stop praying for
what we think we need and we start
connecting and grounding in what could
possibly be of the highest
good for all
and when we stop praying for what we
think we need and we start allowing what
is of the highest good for all so true
manifesting is about receiving what is
of the highest good for all and it
begins not just with what well how will
i get what is of the highest good but
how can i be open to what is of the
highest good how can i open up my
consciousness to release what i think i
need and get grounded in what is
possible
and what is of the highest good not just
for me and my agenda but the highest
good for all that's the message so
you're doing everything right in that
you're
open to a spiritual practice you're
willing to grow you're showing up for
your practice you're reading books
you're doing the work you're here on
dear gabby you're showing up you're
showing up you're showing up you're
doing a lot of doing though and you're
also doing a lot of expecting and so a
lot of doing and a lot of expecting are
two major blocks to your ability to
attract what it is that you want into
your life and so it's the doing doing
doing that actually creates sort of a
manic manifesting vibration which is how
do i get that how do what am i what do i
do next got to do this thing next got to
do this thing next and that lacks the
belief system that i can be still and i
can allow
that's number one
number two being in the expectation of
what you think things should be is
another block to your manifesting power
and your super attractor power which is
what i call it because your expectations
are limiting the possibilities your
expectations are limiting the highest
good as this card says so when we start
to pray for what is of the highest good
rather than intend and pray for what we
think we need that's when the universe
can conspire with what it is that is of
the highest good for all
so ultimately what's happening is all
the doing doing doing is energetically
blocking
and all the expecting expecting
expecting is blocking the manifestation
as well because when you're in this
tunnel vision of expectation it should
be this way i should be further along i
shouldn't be here what's happening is
you're missing the opportunity to
recognize where you are how great things
are in this moment what is possible in
this moment the creative possibility in
this moment the exciting potential in
this moment you're blocking it blocking
it blocking it blocking it blocking it
blocking it
i want you to sit on your
ass i want you to stop doing doing doing
i want you to
start being being
being which is what you also said you're
actually dear gabbying yourself you said
i want to embody the feeling i want to
embody the emotion
the being
is a presence it's an energy it's a
state
it's not an
action true manifesting does require
us to show up for our desires you got to
pick up the phone and then call the job
interview and you have to ask for the
date and you have to to do whatever it
is that you want to create
but ultimately
the greatest source of power that we
have to attract what we want is how we
feel and secret number six the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
study the law with bob proctor i want to
explain something to you
that not many people really understand i
want to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if i let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is the law of
gravity anything heavier than earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work
well
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment your body is a molecular
structure this is a massive energy and a
very high speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was you're just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm is information it's a
multitude of habits you are the product
of your environment but prior to that
you are the product of a genetic strain
that goes back for generations now i'm
going to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in and that
dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does
and the only music you can attract is
the music that is tuned in to the
vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now
talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that y-type done the paradigm will
kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from
to 407 000 in a year and then i took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here
i was cloning stem cells back in 1967
40 years ago
and the significance was while i was
doing this research i was also teaching
medical students so i was teaching
medical students the foundation of how
cells work the conventional story out of
the textbook genes control life what we
call the genetic determinism the belief
that genes control your traits behavior
your physical characteristics etc and
what my research revealed when i was
studying the stem cells was this very
profound i put one stem cell in a petri
dish all by itself and it would divide
every 10 to 12 hours so it'd be 2 4 8 16
cells 32 cells after about two weeks i
have thousands of cells in the petri
dish but what was unique they were all
genetically identical but then i did the
experiment experiment was to take some
cells out of the dish and put them into
a separate dish with a different
environment okay and so the environment
is a culture medium but the culture
medium to cells is like the world that
we live in it's got the air the water
the food all the things in it
so i take the cells out of my stem cell
dish put them in a separate dish with a
different environment and the cells form
muscle
but then i went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells in it
took some cells out put them in a
different environment and they form bone
and then i went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells and put
them in a third petri dish with a
different environment and they form fat
cells and there i was confronted with
this reality all the cells are
genetically identical but they had
different fade fat muscle bone i said
simple question what controls the fate
of cells and the answer is the
environment it was the only thing that
was different because they were all
genetically identical so i started to
really say oh my goodness here i am
teaching genes control life
to the medical students and yet the
cells were revealing to me that hey they
all had the same genes but it was the
environment that i put them in and so
the environment controlled their life
and a very simple experiment that is
very profound for us today is if i took
my dish with plastic petri dish with
cells and it moved it from a healthy
environment to a less than healthy
environment the cells get sick and if i
were a doctor of cells i you might say
well what kind of drugs would you give
these cells and it turns out no you
don't give the cells any drugs you just
take the dish from the bad environment
put it back into a good environment and
the cells will innately naturally come
back to health again i was looking for
relationships i kept failing at them
okay
i end up in the caribbean teaching at a
medical school
the universe throws this into my lap the
perfect pickup line in the whole world
is sort of like hey if you're not doing
anything you want to come and stay in my
villa in the caribbean and hang out i
have a villa on the beach and i got my
own place and
blah blah blah
and i still wasn't able to find anybody
but i kept looking because i said i
need a relationship i need a
relationship so
i meet this woman who comes off of some
yacht and she's you know got a future
that's like she'd do what she wants and
i thought well if you're not doing
anything why don't you uh you want to
come and stay with me in my villa on
this beautiful island
she looked at me and she looked at me
and then she said
i can't be with you and i sort of like
stop for a moment and she looked at me
and she said you're too needy
it hit me i said oh my god
what am i looking for a relationship why
because you're not happy so if you're
looking for a relationship because
you're not happy then you're depending
on that relationship to make you happy
so that's not a nice relationship it's
codependency if i give you this place to
stay you will make me happy that's a
trade you know it's like yes
and after she said that i i was stunned
for a moment i can't be with you you're
too needy she said i was
and then all of a sudden i said thank
you thank you very much it was sort of a
slap in the face right a blessing in
disguise right
it totally was it was like wake up and i
walked away from that and i looked at my
life and said you got this most amazing
job you teach a couple days a week you
live in the caribbean you got a villa
you got money in your pocket because you
get paid and there's nothing to buy in
the caribbean anyways you got i say
you're healthy you got money you've got
a great place to live you have the most
wonderful job i go you can't be happy
with that that's what i said to myself
i said how can i
you know i'm looking for this person to
make me happy i said oh no first i make
me happy yeah and then when i make me
happy
that change and it did what happened is
i stopped bitching and started to enjoy
look don't you love where you live yeah
i love where i live do you love the sea
oh i love the sea you like it oh i love
my job and all of a sudden i started
focusing on hey these are things i love
i guess what
i didn't need anybody
that's when you created abundance and
that's when people became attracted to
you right a hundred percent because once
i didn't need them i wasn't like yeah
where i was like i don't care it's
fascinating how it works then they
showed up they showed up because i did
not need that was the word because need
puts pressure on that other person that
they have to provide
and then they didn't have to provide it
was like hey let me hang out with you i
don't have to provide anything i could
just be me i go yeah you'll be you i'd
be me we have a great time
and that was the beginning of
reprogramming a need for a relationship
until i was happy with myself
and until that had once i was happy with
myself and i didn't need a relationship
you should have seen how many
opportunities showed up that were never
there in my life before because the need
part pushed them away see someone woke
me up that's all i want to do with
someone else what the man said to me the
first guy he said you can have whatever
you want
well you know they get off you good
thinking that you can get out of the box
that's why you've been given an
imagination to get out of the box it's
with your imagination that you build
images of what you want and if you can
build the image you can do it you can
hold it in your head you can hold it in
your hand
when we understand that
like i would imagine this goes out to a
lot of athletes says
well they can they can have anything
they want they got to pay the price
and when doubt comes in kick it out you
can't afford the doubt william james
from harvard said believe and your
belief will create the fact
all things are possible if you believe
well you know i studied for a long time
i started to study this book think and
grow rich and he talks about belief in
here he says you're not ready for what
you want until you believe you can get
it
i found that the
only two sources of reference we could
go to to find out anything about
yourself is science and religion
they all say you've got to believe
so i get figuring out
how do you how do you believe
how do you change a belief
interesting subject because i'm going to
tell you something
your results are nothing but the
manifestation of your belief system
well our belief system of listening
carefully is based upon our evaluation
of something and frequently when we
re-evaluate a situation our belief about
that situation will change
me repeat that
our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something
frequently if we re-evaluate a situation
our belief about it will change
i began re-evaluating who i was i
started to study i never stopped
studying and i found as i re-evaluated i
had a much higher opinion of myself i
found out things about me that i would
have never believed if you had told me
the power that's locked up within us the
marvelous system we've got you know the
blood circulates through your veins
every 33 seconds through hundreds of
miles of passageway bang just like that
colors all the food in and all the
garbage out stop and think of the
central nervous system it's the most
complex electrical system in the world
and you've got it
think of your brain an electronic
switching station like that you can
change the vibration of yourself and
everything around you
we have awesome powers and it's all
based on what you believe about you
napoleon hill and think and grow rich
wrote an entire chapter on decision
most people never make decisions they
have a difficult time with it why is
that
i think they have a difficult time
because their parents made decisions for
them until they were too old
and they never learned how to make them
you know the one thing that i did with
my kids i never made a decision for them
they didn't like it they'd say come on
don't do that to me i said no what do
you think you should do and i'd leave it
at that
decision making is a phenomenal concept
and you're going to find out as he
points out in here the successful people
make decisions very fast and they change
them very slow if and when they change
them at all and he said the people that
have difficulty in life make their
decisions very slow and then change them
fast and often
and you know decision making is a funny
thing you and i think on frequencies if
we can see a bunch of lines and we're
thinking on a frequency
and we're on this frequency here and
we'll say i'm going to do that
when this changes this is never going to
change until you get up on this
frequency see the good that you're after
is on a higher frequency than you're
operating on a greater awareness and if
you're down here and you're thinking
here on this frequency and the good you
want up here you've got to get your mind
up there how do you get up there make
the decision be there and that's really
what you have to do the second you make
a decision you flip your brain onto a
different frequency and you start to
attract things to you that you couldn't
you'd never get without making the
decision dr maxwell mulch wrote a book
back around 1960
it was called self-image psychology
psycho cybernetics it's a phenomenal
book
he said it was the greatest discovery of
his generation
he was a cosmetic or a reconstructive
surgeon and he found he would do work on
people he might have
done a nose job or removed a terrible
scar
and he noticed that when he did that
there was a phenomenal change in their
personality
but he noticed with others he would make
a phenomenal physical change and there
was no change in their personality and
that led him to postulate that we have
two images we have the one that's coming
back from the mirror but we've got an
inner image and that inner self image is
literally controlling our life
you will find people that have a very
poor self-image or low self-esteem they
won't look you straight in the eye
they're afraid to shake hands with you
they're very shy and withdrawn they go
through life hiding from life
they don't like themselves
they don't know themselves
do you know when a person improves their
self-image they change their entire life
their income change their relationship
change their health changes
and you know how you do that
start studying you start to find out
more about you
there's something phenomenal about you
do you know when i began to study this
material
57 years ago i had very poor self-image
i had low self-esteem
i took dumb jobs i never earned any
money i never had fun i had poor
relationships and as i started to study
start to study real solid information
everything in my life started to improve
i've got friends all over the world
today i earn millions of dollars
i'm in my 80s and i get as much energy
as a person in their 30s
you see
when you start to understand really who
you are you're god's highest form of
creation there's things about you that
just about blow your mind as you start
to study and really understand them
you'll walk a little taller
you'll stand a little straighter and you
know something you'll enjoy a whole lot
more of life if i want to do something
i find somebody that's already done it
and then i do exactly what they tell me
it's a simple rule to follow
i um
i don't read novels
i don't watch movies
um
i'd watch documentaries or things like
that where i can learn
and
i'm only interested in
studying
something that can cause me to become
more of what i'm capable of being
see i think we're all hardwired to do
something really special with our life
and
that's all i want to do
i'm really good at what i do
i could walk by a person in the hall
like that i could tell them exactly what
they're like i could read their energy
like a book
everything goes on the inside shows on
the outside see
we're gifted with with faculties of the
mind that the average person knows
nothing about you have intuition the
will reason imagination perception
memory
that's what separates us from all the
rest of forms of life
we go through school never learn
anything about it you'll hear people say
they have a bad memory there's no such
thing as a bad memory everybody has a
perfect memory
it's just weak they've never developed
it
our imagination
your imagination is the most magnificent
he hill said it's the most marvelous
miraculous inconceivably powerful force
the world's ever known
i can use my imagination to project
myself into the future and bring the
future into the present and start living
there
you work from the imagination you don't
work to it
you work from it backwards from the
result yeah have you ever spent any time
wondering how does everything happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
in fact in some places it does
but
i spend a lot of time thinking about
this in fact at times it almost drives
me crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud clone and leaves pop
out
and the leaves generally in the spring
are a very deep greeny brown they're not
a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're most
beautiful it is the most beautiful tree
and it's right outside in my studio
i'm sitting here in my desk and
the camera's around me but
out there is that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
every spring they're greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring
they're always red in the fall and
greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder
why the tide goes way out the tide comes
way back in
i spent some time in the navy in canada
i was down on the east coast for a while
and i was near the bay of fundy do you
know the bay of fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around prince george on the west
coast
you go onto a ship
and you might be walking up a plank just
right straight up and you go off the
ship sometimes you're going right down
that ship goes way up in here and it
comes way down very high very low tide
now someplace the tide's not very big
they do have a tide but not too high not
too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know
just stayed at a certain length you
wouldn't have to cut it but it would
always look pretty
you know
do you think about this do you know that
everything in this universe happens in
an exact way
an exact way
not by chance but in an exact way
when john kennedy
the president of the united states actor
asked dr werner von braun
who was the
mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring him back
safely to earth
von braun answered him in five words the
will to do it that's it the will to do
it
he knew you didn't have to know how to
do it he knew you had to learn how to do
it but you didn't have to know
to make up your mind you were going to
do it now why did he say that because he
understands the laws
von braun one time said after years of
studying the spectacular mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of god and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise
that we don't even have any difficulty
building spaceship we send people to the
moon and we can time the landing with
the precision of a fraction of a second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone i see the laws as god's
modus operandi but i'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law
when you and i
get in harmony with the law now we do
that odds are pretty good we should
understand them but when we get in
harmony with the law then i'm going to
tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
[Music]
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them i'm gonna
you'll shock yourself with the good you
can do now i've been doing that for the
last 58 years i'm starting to get a
really a reasonable grip on them but i
don't understand them as well as i
wanted to or would like to
but i'm going to study a little more
today you know i get my
trusty book out here i'll have to talk
to you about this book
uh that'll be another talk
study the laws find out what they write
what they're like what are the laws and
then study them
you'll win
you ever notice that some people seem to
want to hang on to stuff that is
bothering them they're forever talking
about it they don't want to let it go
they've had a a failure at something and
it's drone they can't get over it they
just can't get over or somebody said
something nasty to them they don't want
to let it go
do you know what we should do we should
ask ourselves everything that happens is
this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
i don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows
the only thing that can grow is the
thing you give energy to why would you
hold on to anything that's not serving
you i want you to think about this i'm
not going to talk about a lot about this
today because i don't think i have to i
just want to let you know that if you're
holding on to something that does not
serve you
you are making a terrible error it's
going to cause all kinds of problems you
may blame other people or other things
you may blame the situation
if you are the cause of the problem
the man that
told me to pick up this book and read it
ray stanford
he had a saying he used to say to me
bob you're the only problem you'll ever
have and you're the only solution
i think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but i do
understand it
and you know something
i am the only problem i'll ever have and
i am the only solution
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you reject it
do you know the beautiful part about
having an inductive reasoning factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you although you cannot change
conditions or circumstance
you don't have to let them control you
we can't control what's going on outside
but we can control what's going on
inside
you know
and
unfortunately i don't think many of us
have been raised to really understand
that yeah
and it's a lack of understanding that's
causing all our problems we are the only
creature on the planet
that's totally disoriented in our
environment
all the little squirrels the birds the
every all the animals
are completely at home in their
environment they blend in
you and i are totally disoriented in our
environment we've been given the mental
faculties to create our own environment
however we go right through school and
we've never learned that
we have higher faculties
and the average person has no knowledge
of how to operate with them how to
develop them we have perception the will
reason imagination memory and intuition
now those mental faculties they're not
just words
they're actually mental faculties that
we can use
to take control over our world and to
create the environment that we want
but unfortunately we grow up we don't
know that
we've been raised to live through by
what we see hear smell taste and touch
our physical senses and we've been
raised to be controlled by what's going
on outside
as little kids will you listen to what
i'm telling you will you look at this
you know and so it's all outside
um we get our report card and that tells
us what kind of student we are
but it really tells us where our mind
was at for a few minutes three weeks ago
got nothing to do with who we are
so i think we're
we're raised in ignorance actually
there's a very small percentage of the
population that
have a reasonably
clear understanding of who they are and
what they're capable of doing but
the ones that do are in the minority
sandy gallagher is my business partner
love her
she is really good
she was going through a very tough time
personally
a number of years ago
we were in phoenix we were doing a
seminar
i had to leave
catch a plane somewhere
and she said before you leave
could we get together maybe for a cup of
coffee
could you um
i want to talk to you and i said sure
so we went across the road to a coffee
shop
and we were sitting there
and she said could you give me two or
three ideas that i could do every day
that would help me through this
i said chair i didn't know what i was
going to tell her but i knew i'd tell
her something
so i said every day
i want you
to take a pen
and write down every morning write down
10 things you're grateful for
but you've really got to be grateful
you've got to feel it you're really
grateful
then i want you
to send love to three people that are
bothering you
they're bothering you you don't like
them
they've got nothing to do with it you're
thinking bad thoughts about them you're
putting yourself in a bad vibration send
love to three people that bother you
and then
take five minutes
and be quiet
just be perfectly quiet
and ask for guidance for the day
everybody in our company does that every
day
she started to do it like that
everything changed
in fact my assistant gina who's been
with me over 30 years
she was working in phoenix and i phoned
gina i told her what i wanted within an
hour she had a pad printed at kinko's
and had it
the ten things
one down to ten you know
send love to three people and bother you
be quiet for five minutes
sandy was going to hawaii with her
sister and her mother the next day
she got pads made for both of them and
every morning they started to do that it
changed every one of their lives
we give that out now in a lot of our
seminars and we train the audience to do
it
start every morning write ten things
that you're grateful for
send love to three people who bother you
be quiet for five minutes and ask for
guidance for the day
it's a winning form you know the people
you surround yourself with have a
phenomenal impact on your life i think
it was carl meneger from the meticulous
foundation one time said
environment is more important than
heredity the people we're surrounded by
have a greater bearing on our life and
our success in life
than what's built into the genes at
birth there's genetic conditioning
there's environmental conditioning well
this environmental conditioning goes on
all the way through life
you will find as you improve the quality
of your life improve your thinking
you're going to attract a different
group of people into your life and they
are going to add to your life
see the people we're surrounded by
their thinking is going right into our
mind
we want to mix with people who are
really making it happen take a look at
your five people that you're with most
often
and ask yourself
if i have children would i want them to
grow up be like them
if the answer is no
you better start looking for some new
friends if the answer is yes you're
already in the right circle of people
think about what i'm saying
the people we're surrounded with have a
phenomenal impact on our life and help
make us who we are you've got to wake up
you see
all we're ever going to get is awareness
we've already got everything
the only thing we lack is the awareness
of what we've got we're god's highest
form of creation there's nothing on the
planet that will equal us
well
that's all we're that's all any of us
are after that's all the problems in the
world come from ignorance
that's the purpose of life overcome
ignorance
develop awareness the only way to
overcome ignorance is through knowledge
and the only way to get the knowledge is
to study
most people they finish school close the
book saying i got it that's over i'm
never going to open another book as long
as i live
they're screwed it's all over you see
the beautiful truth is you've already
got everything you need inside
you don't have to get it
you don't have to follow the pattern
that
our formal educational institutions
teach us
you don't have to read all the books
that's necessary
i think madame montessori put it very
well she said we should send a child to
school
as if they're an empty cup and we expect
them to fill the cup
she's the truth is the cup's already
full school is to help draw what's
already there
you see you and i are god's highest form
of creation there's nothing on the
planet that will even come close to us
strange things you know you and i are
the only creature on the planet that is
totally disoriented in our environment
all those other little creatures they're
completely at home in their environment
they blend in
we don't
we're totally disoriented and that is
because we have the ability united of
creating our own environment
now think of what that means
that means that you and i can literally
create the life we want
now as i said when i first heard that i
did not believe it
but i knew the man that was giving me
the advice believed it and that man was
raymond douglas stanford one of my very
first mentors i like there's a saying on
all of your seminars on the tickets
if you have to borrow money for this
do it it may be the last time
you're doing it listen
when i when i read this
i owed everybody i knew money
but the guy that
told me he said don't clean officer for
somebody else do them for yourself and
he told me where i could buy a used
floor machine and some buckets and mops
it was going to cost 980
i mean i didn't know anyone would lend
me money because i never paid them back
not that i didn't want to i just never
had any money
well i searched and searched and
searched and i found a guy that lent me
a thousand dollars
so when somebody tells me they can't
borrow money i know that they haven't
tried
i think anybody can borrow a thousand
dollars somewhere
and that's what i did
and i turned it into a multi-million
dollar organization
i sat down one day with my pen
in this business i said i'm going to
build a company that operates all over
the world we operate all over the world
so if you have to borrow money
borrow the money
but get into the business
actually do it right now i'm standing in
the middle of my library this is my
favorite place you know earl nightingale
said if you surround your mind with
greatness some of it's gonna rub off
well hopefully some of it is rubbed off
on me i have maybe three or four
thousand books here on the shelf they're
all in alphabetical order uh by author
they're all catalogued so i know where
to find something just like that i go by
authors more than the title of the book
do you know that
when i started studying these books i
really didn't know very much about
anything i had two months high school i
was 26 years old i had a bad work record
a bad attitude
and virtually no experience and you know
in a relatively short period of time my
income went from four thousand to 175
000 a year then it went over a million
in order for you to to really begin to
explore the unknown aspect of yourself
you got to learn how to get beyond the
known aspect of yourself and if you keep
coming back to the known you're going to
miss out on the unknown so you would say
well i don't know anything in the
unknown of course it's the unknown and
if you try to control it there you're
back to the known if you try to predict
it you're back to the known so you got
to go through this trial and error of
just kind of refining your attention
refining your ability and and it's just
got to be something like playing tennis
or playing golf or doing martial arts or
working out or crocheting or stance in
the salsa you just got to keep going man
in the beginning it's tedious and then
when you start finding your groove like
our our community
they don't miss their morning
meditations yeah you know why because
the magic is happening and they know if
they miss it they're gonna they're gonna
cut off from the magic so they whether
they're tired whether they're hungover
whether they're what they're right
they're in right you know and if you if
you wake up in the morning
and you can't get your butt out of bed
you know what that means it just means
you can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
your life your body's resigned
so then so then you know when you went
on a school trip when you were a kid you
know you woke up before your parents
because you knew something new is going
to happen that's the body going wake up
wake up it's something unexpected is
going to happen what happened to us
christmas day
so why not
you know put in your put in your time
and then and then measure the effects of
you would cause i mean become a
scientist in your life
and really start to experiment with it
okay let me change my energy let me just
write down four thoughts
that like i can it's too hard i'll start
tomorrow this doesn't feel right
whatever it is it's be this person's
fault just write those down and say
these thoughts like gandalf on the
bridge yes you may not pass today this
is the end yes so then if you become
conscious of those thoughts now you're
the governor of your thoughts what what
what actions what behaviors do you want
to change do you complain you blame you
judge do you make excuses how do you
talk do you speak limited just pick four
things that you're not going to do any
longer yeah
what emotions get you in trouble what
are the emotions that you're addicted to
too right that you're addicted to that
keep you returning back to your past if
you don't know
close your eyes for about 30 minutes and
just watch where your mind goes and
watch your feelings and just say okay
it's frustration it's unworthiness it's
self-doubt it's guilt it's frustration
it's shame
just become conscious of those and just
review them in your mind so that you
don't go unconscious them in your waking
day i believe in human possibility human
potential and i think that one of our
biggest
limiting beliefs is the belief have how
limited we really are
and so my interest is to give people
the science to begin to understand how
powerful they really are and i think
that science really is the language that
does that really well and and the new
sciences like quantum physics and
neuroplasticity neuroscience
neuroendocrinology you know
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all of those
sciences point the finger at
possibilities so i want to create a
language for people
from a philosophical or theoretical
standpoint for them to begin to
understand what's possible but then i
want to be able to have those people
begin to wire that information in their
brain completely because learning is
making new connections right in the
brain
but remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections and it's so
much easier to lose our vision than to
remember it right so then we have to
begin to hardwire the brain or install
the neurological hardware
in preparation for an experience so the
more people understand what they're
doing and why
then the how gets easier so i want to
then set up the conditions in an
environment in a in a in a workshop
where people can begin to
apply or personalize what they learn so
that they can have an experience and
experience then further enriches the
brain but the prize of an experience is
an emotion and once you start feeling
unlimited once you start feeling
abundant once you start feeling worthy
now you're teaching your body chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so knowledge
is for the mind and experiences for the
body and people begin to embody the
truth of that philosophy now if they can
repeat it over and over again
it'll become innate in them and become
natural second nature become easy they
begin to master that philosophy so i
want people to begin to understand that
thoughts are very powerful feelings
drive our thoughts
and that they can begin to create a
better life for themselves once they
understand some of these principles we
have research to show that 60 days of
meditation
five days a week
will lengthen your life the telomeres
the little shoestrings on the end of
your dna get longer that means your
biological age is changing
so we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
i mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's
having a transcendental moment and we
now know that we can predict it and we
now know that we can induce it so then
there's the evidence there because most
people are waiting for their life the
change yeah so they can feel gratitude
to feel abundance to feel whole you know
that's the old model of cause and effect
you know so if you're living with
emptiness you're living with lack you're
living with pain
most people have been conditioned that
something out there has to take away
this emptiness or feeling inside of them
but
if you believe that you're creating your
life
and you're living by lack well lack is
going to create abundance right so
so then it makes sense then that you
don't really actually
create wealth you generate wealth you
generate abundance so the moment you
start teaching your body emotionally
what that future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest well your body
is the unconscious mind believes it's
living in that future in the present
moment now it's the scientific fact that
it's the environment that signals the
gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion
so when you begin to embrace an elevated
emotion you're beginning to signal the
gene ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that well genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and the function of
your body and the expression of proteins
is the expression of life so by you
creating an elevated emotion and
teaching your body what that future will
feel like before it's made manifest your
body's starting to live in that future
reality in the present moment now here's
the key
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom and you're able to
generate those chemicals every single
day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen you
would already feel like it has happened
now what is the importance of that well
you're literally becoming somebody else
so you're leaving your lack you're
leaving your guilt you're leaving your
emptiness behind your personality
literally yet is made up of how you
think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life
your personal reality you got to change
your personality and here we go again
you got to start becoming conscious of
your unconscious thoughts you got to
start noticing how you act how you speak
you got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth you
speak about the neurophysiology of
forgiveness
sure
think
about frozen circuits
frozen circuits
or hardwired circuits
the more profound
the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and you keep
doing it enough times it's no longer
conscious that you're holding a grudge
it's no longer conscious
that
you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody
is that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality
you're not seeing it the way it is
you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception
triggers the emotion in the network and
you're back in your past and you're
acting like you were when it happened
are you with me still
and so then the person says i'm not that
person you say oh no i know i just had
this event in my past and i'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting
and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers
you're releasing
the life force into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere in no time and the identity and
the personality is gone which energy is
going to move it's got to it's going to
follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold a grudge
are you with me still yes
so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still
so then from a quantum perspective you
are actually
as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage
because of that person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience and you have an
energetic bond that's connecting you to
them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that
energetic agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change
in your emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start
lowering the volume to that emotion and
the body starts liberating energy and
you're calling your energy back to you
because the lower the volume of the
emotion the less you're going to pay
attention to that person there comes a
moment where there's a snap there's a
release the energy is broken
and once it's broken now all of a sudden
you free yourself
and
you free them
and
this has happened to me in my life
the people show up 10 years later
completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and i let them go
so then
forgiveness
from a quantum perspective and a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
that's all it is
and when you start getting happy with
yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for the
grudge you were holding because this
feels too good
are you with me still
now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending in energy to
the brain the heart acts as an amplifier
to boost the brain
are you with me still
so then once the energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin when you
feel more loved then you feel the grudge
so then you
think why would i want to give this up
for that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation
and oxytocin then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites
as fear and it lowers the volume to fear
and anxiety it shuts the lights out for
aggression and anger and hostility and
it cools the circuits off for suffering
and pain and the only thing you can feel
is a love for life
and that's when you're free now the
practice
of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it's
it takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like i don't want to forgive him yeah
[Music]
halfway forgive him
and just never really authentic
forgiveness
do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and
she had severe
severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
she came to our event
in
in
tacoma washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
oneness
in the
and that frequency had a message for her
and it said and she was an incredible
bliss when this happened
i sent four angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her terrors
that was the end
of her night she couldn't have a
relationship she couldn't she could not
live with anybody she was
she was isolated
one moment the divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy moved right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for
now she's healed she's healthy she's
happy and she's on with a new life she's
born again my mother would love this
she's born again in the same life
reborn in the same way didn't pass
through a birth canal for it
she just was born again
in the same life she got a new lease in
one instant
that energy was carrying a message
and it made its way all the way into the
body and the bliss and the joy and the
gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried what
made total sense to her
she's free one instant
to me that's true forgiveness
that's the divine having its way with
you you get your ass kicked along the
way things go sideways things go wrong
people let you down partners don't work
out money falls out all these things
happen but i want you to reframe it in
your mind success auditor success tax
auditor is looking looking and going
okay let's put another obstacle in front
of wendy's way let's see if she can get
through that oh she saw the obstacle
turn around went back i don't think
she's going to be the one that reaches
her full potential but she could just
live life like everybody else and she'll
be okay
let's see about liberio let's see what's
up liberia let's throw some crap in
front of him let's throw some fears in
front of him let's throw a massive
obstacle wow
he fought it he was a little sad it was
a little tough a little stressful a
couple sleepless nights but he's still
going okay check that box
let's wait about three months and throw
some more [ __ ] in his way and that's
what i believe success tax is i think we
have to go through the trials and
tribulations we have to build the grit
we have to build the wisdom
or else we don't deserve it i teach my
daughter she's killing it in softball i
said you win when no one else is
watching you have to pay your success
tax by practicing all the time when no
one's cheering no one's excited no one's
doing it over the summer she's down here
in my office pitching
because she's paying her success tax but
guess what in the fall when she plays
she's gonna kill it when she comes out
and all her friends can be like oh my
god everybody's admiring you got the
game ball i wish i could do that you
wish you could do it pay success tax
if you're not willing to pay get out of
the freaking game
don't think it says listen everybody
wants to be on stage in front of 50 000
people jamming and singing with
everybody going crazy in the crowd
singing their name but you know what
everybody's not willing to do is play in
their room until their fingers bleed to
pack up an old van and drive around to
gig to get when two people show up most
people aren't willing to do that
everybody looks at the beatles on how
amazing they were right you know the
beatles played like ten thousand
different uh over over the years they
played almost every night like six
nights a week sometimes two gigs a night
for years and years and years never
being noticed sometimes one person in
the audience they paid their success tax
and then all of a sudden they were an
overnight sensation they weren't an
overnight sensation so think of it that
way frame it as success tax is part of
the journey and if you could say i'm not
saying you need to like the crap
i'm not saying you have to like the
journey i'm not saying you have to like
when somebody screws you over the deal
goes sideways
but what if you go wow if i get through
this
i get another checkbox from the success
tax auditor you start looking at life
that way things change and you realize
you're here
because you're learning those skills to
get through them easier and quicker most
of the world most of the world sees a
wall and they turn around and go back
they're not deserving of the success you
are the type that will pound through it
get under it get around it climb over it
or blow it up with dynamite and that's
who wins the game so with that said
let's take it a step further
because i can talk about this until i'm
blue and like i could talk about this
every moment of every day when it comes
to my business because i've crushed it
in my business those fears that i had of
being a broke kid i didn't i didn't have
the right education i didn't go to
college i didn't have money i didn't
come from the right town my parents both
worked to make you know probably 35
grand combined separately and we always
stressed about money and i lived in a
bathroom with my dad i lived in a
trailer park with my mom until we got
evicted i mean crazy stuff right in
business i overcame all those fears i
failed miserably winston churchill said
the definition of success is going from
failure to failure without losing your
enthusiasm well i i did that before i
ever read that quote and i kept going i
paid my success tax i failed miserably
and i made it and in business i can make
those decisions i can i can fail
miserably i can lose millions of dollars
on a deal and i could be over in a day i
could i could have faith in someone i'm
working with and they let me down and it
hurts and i'm over in a day i can
rebound fast learn from it and go i have
trained my body i've trained my my my
insides i've trained my physiology i've
trained my words i've trained my
subconscious that we are freaking
unstoppable nothing as a combined body
and unit nothing can stop us i feel like
most people in their lives
are being allowed to live small
you're allowed to live a small life
everyone around you would like you to
live small just do this you're good at
that man take it easy chill when's
enough enough like come on brother you
know
we're weak all these message you get is
basically saying hey man live small yeah
life's not a big deal live small enjoy
it chill smoke a little weed do whatever
you want to want right like it's just
this get by thing in life and there's
got to be some people go no
no you're supposed to do something great
with your life you were put here for a
purpose your way the way you were born
the way you were raised your background
your experiences your giftedness all
prepared you in your way for right now
and you're supposed to do something
great with your life you weren't born
here to be average and ordinary
and there's all this messaging that
you're averaging ordinary and you're
averaging because you belong there and
it's probably someone else's fault
you're averaging ordinary too i'm like
no it's your life you're in control it's
no one else's fault and you're supposed
to do something magnificent that's the
consciousness aspect the last
thousand years on earth doing something
great has been reserved to this one
little group of people one percent of
the population they're supposed to do
something great they're supposed to live
their dreams we're supposed to watch
them cheer for them wear their jersey
watch their award show
comment on their posts clean their
houses right feed them in their
restaurants no the fact of the matter is
you can do those things you can change
your life and i'm sick and tired of this
hero worship you live small cheer for
everybody else who lives big no if
you're a school teacher be the best damn
school teacher change the world by those
little lives you're affecting if you're
on social media change the world play
big you will never do it wrong if your
decision is to do the bigger thing than
the smaller thing that's what i would
tell you stop playing small stop
thinking small and don't let anybody
tell you you should be small i believe
that fear gets way too much airplay you
know i think so many people say well
people don't take action because they
have too much fear or fear is holding
people back and i think this is so
common in our language it's almost the
point where it's almost comedic it's
ridiculous it's like well what are they
fearful of what are they so scared of
you know we we live in the modern world
right now where there's not all these
impulsive fears that are are driven by a
physical reality to be safe you know
we're not being chased by animals that
are trying to kill us often right so
most of the fears that we actually have
are just negative contemplative thoughts
that we're rerunning too often and we're
associating so much pain to that now
becomes convenient oh it's fear as if
some fear is some big unknowable scary
awful thing well mostly it's not most
fear is just bad management of our own
mental faculties it's not an impulsive
physical thing generating in our brain
telling us to you know fight fight or
flee and everyone wants to use that
excuse you know we still have all these
you know biological psychologists or
people running around saying well it's
just an impulsive thing that people
can't understand or or or be conscious
of right it's the unconscious fears it's
just wiping us out it's like get over it
neuroscience has shown like we have much
more powerful capabilities than most of
us think that we do and the reality is
most fear
once you understand what it actually is
and it usually is a contemplative
process and once they understand what it
is then it's like oh we can overcome it
because what is it then i mean what is
fear what are we so scared of what's
going to hurt us what is this thing that
we fear is going to bring so much pain
in our lives ever thought about it what
is it
what is the thing that we're so scared
that's going to bring in all this pain
to our lives
i remember figuring this out for myself
and when i did i wasn't so scared
anymore because sometimes you know the
things once you understand them more
they're not so terrifying once something
becomes knowable you can develop
competency around it once you can
develop competency around it then you
can develop confidence around it there's
this old thing in psychology we call the
competence confidence loop the more you
understand something the more confidence
you have in that area same thing with
anything that does happen to impulsively
generate some fear in yourself well now
once you understand what it is you can
deal with it better because what we're
all fearing is basically three types of
pain three areas that we might
experience pain in our lives and once we
understand that we can reorient our lot
our mindset around those things and no
longer be frustrated or stopped by fear
you know the first thing that we fear
pain in in our lives is what i call loss
pain
loss pain is well if i change my life or
i do this new thing i'll experience loss
and because i experience loss i don't
want to do it so i'm scared to try it
because i might lose something that i
like i care for i adore i might if i go
and make that big change in my life i
might lose my job i might lose my
relationship with my spouse i might lose
my connection with my kids i might lose
a passion i might lose a benefit right i
remember when i wanted to go and start
my own business everyone was
generating all this fear in you by
saying well be careful you know this is
very dangerous brendan you don't you
don't want to quit your job and lose all
that security you have you're gonna i
mean what about your 401k brendan you're
going to lose your 401k i mean all these
things we think we're going to fear and
the reality was part of that was true
as i thought more about the situation i
was concerned i was fearful that i would
lose the security i had that the job
provided i would lose that steady
paycheck we all want i would lose that
predictability of my career path i would
lose that nice process of having
managers around to kind of coach and
consult me into higher levels of
performance i would lose the peer set i
love my co-workers
i lose some of the work that i loved i
would lose that great lunch and
cafeteria you know it's like you think
of all these things you're going to lose
so you don't make the decision to quit
same thing like people are going to try
and uh you know quit uh you know smoking
or they're going to try and start a diet
they're fearful that they're going to
lose that that smoking break that gives
them that peace and that comfort and
that that sense of calmness from
breathing in deep even though they're
bringing in death you know they they're
fearful oh well if i change my diet i'm
going to lose those foods that i love so
much so i'm not going to change
and that's what people do they're
fearing loss
so part of reorienting our lives is
start focusing on the things that
instead of what we're going to lose of
what we're going to gain
yeah i might lose my security for the
short term but over the long term i
might have more freedom i might gain
freedom i i might lose that coaching and
that that that person who's going to
develop me in terms of that
organizational structure but over here
i'm going to gain greater challenges i'm
going to grow faster because i'm going
to be doing things faster on my own oh
you know i'm going to lose that 401k
yeah but i'm going to make a million
dollars over here you know focusing on
those gains see what happens in the in
the fearful mind it starts asking this
question what if
and it follows that phrase with a
negative statement what if this terrible
thing happens what if this terrible
thing happens what if this terrible
thing happens and we generate and we
stew within our gut these acids and
these fears that literally trick our
mind into thinking we can't change but
once you understand lost pain is
something you're dealing with
start focusing more on the things that
you will gain and you're getting over a
hurdle
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want 10 amazing
rules for success from dr joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy so if you're shifting your
attention all over the board your energy
is scattered yeah so then when you start
disconnecting from everybody your boss
your co-worker you know